une aciérie en activité 24 heures sur 24
c'est un spectacle qui a ses amateurs
plus de dix mille visiteurs chaque année
dans l'union domaine de sollac aux
portes de la camargue à fos sur mer
ce toit tandis qu'un cargo reprend le
large en laissant derrière lui une
montagne 2000 reste un client un groupe
de médecins de la région hôte en
partance pour la route de l'asie
et devancé au fondement de persuadé
grosse cuba ce sont tout simplement les
gaz au maine alors le plus grand on ne
débat nous quand ils parcourent le
domaine du gaz aux fourneaux c'est le
chinois gaston se transforme en coop les
capacités de 128 il faut affronter la
chaleur lie aux fourneaux où le minerai
de fer et le groupe ce changement points
à 1402 été un peu chaud la demande pour
les pc portables problème
pas une minute à perdre les visiteurs du
pouvoir veulent connaître la suite
mais ça manque pas
le hangar du nantais
mais chut
le plus impressionnant c'est que tout
marche tout fonctionne et comme moi
jamais personne pour pratiquement
personne
une épreuve reproche quoi se féliciter
mais quand on est gamin on a toujours
peur du feu des choses comme ça et je
trouve que c'est c'est tellement immense
et c'est tellement chaud c'est tellement
bruyant à l'appel vraiment le chaudron
de l'enfer motion voulant faire du faux
diplômes de certains plats les brames
à obtenir l'épaisseur souhaitait vient
ensuite la bûche froide
merci ressemble enfin de l'acier et se
laisse embobiner docilement comme une
toile
un exportations je peux vous dire que
lorsque ces profils ont cassé la
frontière italienne voit très palamas du
sud pour 48 heures minimum en moyenne
pour refroidir une voisine de la table
ils étaient venus pour s'instruire et
ils n'ont pas été déçus de toi la visite
a duré quatre heures
mais on prétend que parfois certains
poussent le vice jusqu'à y passer la
nuit entière